we were talking about gay vampires in it
was earlier it was literally five
minutes
well we talking about gay vampires you
started what was I talking about
no just say it I wanted to go be clear
about you weren't in the room a friend
of yours who has come crusts no that's
all right then it went into long enough
come even you wouldn't you'd have to
leave the come on your face long enough
for it define our our you know how their
please an animal wipe the face off when
that comes on there
do you guys don't trust fi it bother
does it bother you when people have like
white crust on the side of the mouth
when they speak I have it know lately
I've been having it I don't know how you
even said it a couple like last week you
said it you have that white come across
things donut oh that's what it was it
was like we don't naturally I don't have
no idea I think people who like to a lot
of gum and get that like little white
thing yeah I was talking about Peter Kim
so Peter came and I pitched the show the
Peter and Peter out essentially but a
lot of it has Papa's involved we're
involved right and so he might have sold
it and so all I was saying is and that's
how we got into you know I mean that he
i was joking around saying that peter's
a gay vampire and you know sometimes I
let him suck to come out on my dick I go
bite into it with your you know mean
because I'd rather just suck it out so
he doesn't spite that you know mean he
wants to he wants just me to squirt the
[ __ ] in his mouth because once I'm so
funny have you seen his Instagram story
today it's actually all about calm can I
bring it for you yeah yes it makes sense
that you would think this about Peter
can fear let me and what I mean I'm
proving my point
yeah shout out to Peter I love Pirlo
Peter here he got his instagrams he's
addicted to it he laid them tar for me
and then they started support squirt
squirt squirt squirt squirt squirt
squirt squirt squirt have to swear does
squirt squirt squirt squirt it's worth
after sport after squirt all drenched
squirt Bobby's not lying guys does that
sound like a gay vampire who says squirt
that many time gay vampires
Peter cam if you look at his story it's
all about come today okay I swear to god
yeah he was like it's not what you think
and it was like there's something on his
body and then the next then second part
of his story is like just kidding it's
come that's come Christ you know what
God [ __ ] up I just thought of this is
a third sack for so you have two sacks
right for the calm there's a third sack
in between the two sexes that's a little
smaller science alert science alert you
know what it is
it's like those Coke machines yes choose
the different flavouring right you can
go diet even no sugar yeah right who's
the flavoring for my gum so you can
enjoy your own Cano I mean I would check
out the flavors yeah if I went to the
store thing we have new flavors that I
would be like take it let's see if
samples probably yeah you take a little
sample put in the third sack that little
one right hey root beer yeah it's pretty
close and you're like look creamy you
know means but yeah I think God should
have done that that'd be cool the third
little sack with flavoring yeah all
right anyway when I die I have notes for
God do you have that you have notes for
God I have like human notes like third
Zach what else would you write you know
about this you know about my other one
the anus at the bottom of the foot
oh yeah that's the easy that's the
easiest that come on mm-hmm you mean you
could [ __ ] anywhere you're sure though
your shoe has an opening your shoe has a
little mechanism those click-click the
anus is at the heel right you stick your
foot you you could stick your foot in a
hole right and you're [ __ ] like this
right it's you're right in a hole right
and you go hey Danny yeah how's Margo oh
she's getting good grades yeah
excuse me for a second
Shh yeah God take notes
yeah but the flavor packs butthole on
the bottom of the foot what else we'd
have to like [ __ ] you would have to [ __ ]
feet if you like anal yeah if you were
like anal okay yeah
so then you could still do it so West
Hollywood you just write write write
walk it down let's put 5 it yeah yeah or
maybe like or maybe the gate the gay
man's right leg were to look that the
hole is the right foot is much more
muscular oh it's like our because they
use it like get a different kind of what
is Claire yeah yeah right right and then
like you know guys like Elon Musk's they
put like you know mean like an extra
like electrical like future leg thing
where it's like a power leg we learn so
much that we should be inventors yeah
ideas yeah we should be inventors